[Musique]
avant le mouvement des policiers prévue
demain gérald darmanin a annoncé qu'il
se rendrait vous le savez à la
manifestation pour les soutenir alors un
ministre qui manifestent on n'avait
jamais vu ça
ces manifestations pour la république
que celle des policiers et je serais je
vais leur dire à la fois mon soutien et
ma présence dans dire qu'effectivement
nous sommes tous ensemble dans le même
bateau on n'a jamais vu un ministre de
la république manifester contre sa
politique
donc c'est une façon pour monsieur
darmanin de s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités
non il va pas manifestés poudre contre
lui-même évidemment il sera dans son
rôle de ministre de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire deux premiers policiers de
france
il ira saluer les policiers dans un
moment je pense qu'il est essentiel que
la nation toute entière montre à quel
point nous sommes derrière nos forces de
l'ordre demain il ne s'agit pas d'un
hommage au policier
contrairement aux apparences de man il
s'agit d'une manifestation revendicative
d'organisation policières qui ont un
cahier de revendications avec lequel
nous sommes en radicale des accords
alors que le son n'est pas séché alors
que des policiers sont assassinés de et
après les propos ignominieux de votre
président de groupe ignominieux vous
arrivez encore à mettre un degré
supplémentaire à la bassesse et on voit
bien ce qu'il veut exprimer ce que nous
avons tous besoin d'exprimer tous les
parlementaires qui seront là au contact
avec les policiers
les policiers nous protège et on a le
sentiment que personne ne les protègent
eux c'est une pantomime ce petit
harlequins de beauvau qui court après
toutes les émotions c'est pas gênant que
d'une certaine manière gérald darmanin
il cautionne finalement une
manifestation qui va critiquer
clairement eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux bien au contraire
gérald darmanin et solidaire de tout le
gouvernement il est solidaire des
policiers dont il est le premier en
france
il court à la manif des policiers pour
faire croire qu'elle est d'accord avec
les policiers alors si tout le monde est
d'accord avec tout le monde n'y a plus
de solution
mais demain manifester que monsieur
darmanin pour faire pression sur
ministre de l'intérieur face est
incompréhensible
je pense même que les policiers
la base vont un peu être choqués on a lu
par cette récupération politicienne
c'est qu'ils abattent l'ordre
républicain comme les prolonger votre
idéologie mortifère vous désarmer la
police nationale par vos propos et vos
insultes
vers la fin du port du masque
obligatoire à l'extérieur on y arrivera
bientôt a indiqué ce matin le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand castex il
est beaucoup plus claire que que le
docteur verron l'auteur le ministre la
vérité de howell et des j'ai vu chez
vous sur votre antenne et des as pour la
grée pourra remettre des masques
bien sûr mais j'aime mon ami est le
doyen rivaux historiques
le groupe m6 a annoncé que bouygues et
sa filiale tf1 voulait racheter 30% de
son capital
bouygues devrait débourser plus de 640
millions d'euros pour sceller cette
fusion ça gagne combien par mois
ministre alors aujourd'hui je suis à 5 9
s'est transformé de bêtises grâce à ce
projet de fusion entre tf1 et m6 le
chiffre d'affaires de l'entité s'élève à
3,4 milliards d'euros cumulés une place
prépondérante sur le plan européen pour
résister à une concurrence de plus en
plus puissantes certains ont même
commencé à avoir des visions etxebeste
d'autres encore pas d'avoir des fusions
partout et ils vont lancer l'amour et
dans koh lanta et danse avec le meilleur
pâtissier ça va être le feu déraillement
spectaculaire d'entrain dans l'état de
l'iowa aucun blessé pour l'instant n'est
à signaler les causes de l'accident sont
inconnues mais vous le voyez 47 wagons
ont déraillé